The first point we need to consider is for
store instructions, when does the memory write actually happen?
And it happens at commit. We have to do
writes to memory at commit because it is unsafe
to update memory at any point before the instruction
commits. Any instruction that has not yet committed is
subject to being canceled. For example, because of a
branch misprediction or exception. So doing a memory write prematurely
might mean that later we have to undo access to
memory, meaning we have to kind of put back the
old value of a memory location which is extremely difficult
to do. So what we will do is we will delay
memory writes and restores untill commit. But does it mean
that the load has to also wait until commit before it
can get data, because only then the data is in
memory? So the question is, if we write values on stores
at commit, where does the load get data? And
we want our loads to get data as early
as possible, so that we can finish those loads
and supply that data to the subsequent instructions that
depend on the load. For this purpose, we introduce
a structure called load-store queue. And that is where
we will keep all loads and stores, and we
will next see how loads get data from the stores.